sometimes I don't trust love at first
sight not even when a car looks this
good so I decided to put the Tesla Model
X through its paces for five days in the
mountains along the California coast I
needed to know was this just a crush or
a lasting love affair I first drove the
$151,000 SUV briefly in Los Angeles last
year and at the time thought it was one
of the best cars I'd ever tested but a
340 mile road trip can make or break any
relationship one push of the button and
the Model X will automatically route
your trip according to where the
superchargers line up it probably won't
be the fastest route but you know you
won't run out of juice we were on our
way it was the start of something
beautiful
the seats are situated high inside but
they're easy to access even the back row
and the interior cabin is so quiet I can
hear crickets chirping outside as I
drove with the windows up the car has
almost no body roll around corners and
it handled beautifully on a sandy beach
I will say that the battery gauge can be
deceiving it doesn't decrease at a
stable rate so you can jump down and
range a lot quicker than you expect left
this morning with a full charge and
we've been driving for four hours or so
so we're down to about 77 miles on the
battery so I asked the car to find us
the closest supercharger and we're
driving there now and we should get
there in about 12 minutes
turns out I had some major time to kill
hey grandma oh nothing much how are you
back on the road I could focus on the
feel of the all-wheel drive test the 3.2
seconds 0 to 60 mile per hour sprint
time and the 760 to equivalent
horsepower
it feels really fast when you push down
the gas pedal the brakes are
regenerative so you have to get used to
their different feel I never really did
and the automatic front doors can be
tricky they open when you least expect
it at the end of this trip I realized
the real question here is not should you
buy this car but do you want to join the
electric lifestyle you really do feel
virtuous when you drive it no fossil
fuels here but owning an electric car
saps your time and energy if you're not
deliberate about charging it makes it
harder to be spontaneous and free and
you have to be ok with giving up the raw
pure feeling of driving a mechanical car
but if you are that kind of driver the
kind that wants to be on the cutting
edge of luxury and technology you're
going to fall in love